[Music]  listen for the best Maya beauticians  never been worse so it was like me for  me Taylor Swift is unapologetically  herself in her new music video for  delicates and we are so here for it we  can't make any promises now can we be  but you can make me drink filmed over  two days in downtown Los Angeles we see  Taylor get handed a note which turns her  invisible she embraces the moment by  acting goofy and dancing passionately in  the hotel the subway and outside in the  rain  [Music]  look closely the sign above Taylor's  head to the left says Joe's deli  seemingly a nod to her bow Joe Alwyn the  couple was first linked in May 2017  they've kept their relationship under  wraps but fans seem to think several  lyrics are about their romance  [Music]